[Musik]
Menschen haben Ziele beim Triathlon
zählen für die meisten nur Zeit und rang
Menschen haben Narben doch oft sieht man
sie nicht
philipp hat so viele Narben dass ihr die
Blicke auf sich zieht das ist ihm
unangenehm und kostet Kraft nur schon am
Start zu stehen fühlt sich für ihn darum
an wie ein Sieg mentaler nehme
natürlich mit dem Triathlon abschließen
ein Triathlet der nicht nur möglichst
schnell ankommen will
ein Triathlet dessen größter Gegner die
Blicke der Anderen sind
[Musik]
doch an diesem Septembermorgen in
Locarno hat Philipp seine Angst einmal
mehr besiegt
das ist im Kanton Aargau gesehen am 2
juni 2014
mit Elektroden
[Musik]
und das hat sich dann im Endeffekt
schlussendlich auch gesammelt und dann
eigentlich eine zu deinem Inferno
geführt die da der Röhren
[Musik]
aber das ist eigentlich fast der
harmlosere Teil vom Ganzen sie im
Führerinnen nachher natürlich
mit der Hut und mit der Gedanke daran
was ich habe das früher gesehen
aber
vorstellig was es ausgelöst hat und man
die Kleider weg sind und wenn der Körper
ausgesät und und das ist
das ist für mich die Einstiege
Philipp wird ins Unispital Zürich
geflogen in die Intensivstation
verbrannt verletzte er wird ins
künstliche Koma versetzt
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass man schweren
Unfall überlebt sind irgendwo zwischen
fünf und zehn Prozent maximal gewesen
Russ Schmutz und blasen werden in der
eintrittswanne entfernt alle Haare
werden rasiert wegen der
Infektionsgefahr die Haut ist so weiß
weil sie nicht mehr durchblutet wird die
tote Haut muss weggeschnitten werden
es ist ein beschädigter Schutzmantel
aber das ist der letzte Moment wo diesen
Schutzmantel anhat und den entfernt man
dann
Prozent von Philips Haut sind verbrannt
in den ersten 30 Tagen wird er 20-mal
operiert die Wunden sollen so schnell
wie möglich vernarben um den Körper vor
Keimen zu schützen
man versucht auf die Wunden wo die Haut
entfernt wurde kleinste hautinseln zu
transplantieren bei jemand der so schwer
verbrannt ist hat man natürlich von
dieser eigenen Haut sehr wenig zur
Verfügung und macht dann in vielen
kleinen Punkten so wie sie das hier auf
dem Bild sehen können so einen
Schachbrettmuster um die verfügbare Haut
auszudehnen
und die wird dann mit sogenannter
spenderhaut
übertransplantiert und da sehen Sie hier
wie diese kleinen braunen in sich hin
sich eigentlich durch diese spenderhaut
durcharbeiten und ausbreiten die
spenderhaut funktioniert wie ein Gerüst
wo sich die eigene Haut die eigenen
Hautzellen entwickeln können und das
endet dann im Prinzip in der
vollständigen Wundheilung wo sie mit
ganz wenig Haut eigentlich eine große
Fläche erzeugt haben
es gibt Tage die weniger gut sind und wo
einem wirklich auch die Kraft fehlt aber
was ihn auszeichnet ist wirklich dass er
eigentlich was immer wie immer
Möglichkeiten gegeben haben das hat er
genommen und hat für sich damit was
angefangen und sein Weg gesucht
Altstadt Bülach mir gefällt es sehr so
Altbau und der alte Kern genauso
aufgewachsen
da habe ich letzte Stück wieder
Anonymität und Leute mir so gerne wenn
ich bin und
ich Vergangenheit
das ganze aufwachsen weniges Thema bist
du in einem Unfall ohne dann
also wenn ich mir nicht zu viel wir
bewegen jetzt sei bei der Ganztag oder
mit den Übungen und Physiotherapie ist
es hier
schlimmste Szenario das
jahrelbständigkeit verlieren also dass
sie nicht mehr Alltag bewältigen das
fängt ganz Bewegungsapparat da
vielleicht das Beispiel
am stärksten und ich verwoben
[Musik]
besser wird und haben
und und mehr machen und bloß das hat
mich
im Kopf sehr unterstützt also auch
seelisch sehr unterstützt und ja sie
Täter ist eigentlich der Sport zu Mini
eigen Therapie wurde
[Musik]
Schwimmtraining
ausnahmsweise an einem verregneten
Samstagnachmittag sonst geht philipp am
Morgen schwimmen um anderen Menschen aus
dem Weg zu gehen
meine erste Blick ist immer noch der
Autobahnausfahrt sind wir eigentlich
gerade auf der Parkplatz wie viel Auto
das hat und ja das wird es mit einer
eigentlich auch nichts
schlecht und wird auch am liebsten
wieder umkehren aber
ich muss Schwimmtraining absolvieren und
ich habe mir verbessern und vor allem
mit Konfrontation stellen
ja das trifft miteinander das
merkt wie sehr stark dass sie irritiert
sind echt gut
von mir und das wird die wenig auslösen
und und das trifft miteinander will man
merkt wie die Menschen
abschweifen will sie hat überfordert
sind und leben
Parkplatz der Parkplatz ist
[Musik]
wie immer Philipp zieht die Blicke auf
sich
[Musik]
diese Herausforderung stellt er sich
zwei bis dreimal pro Woche
Philipp will nur eines so schnell wie
möglich ins Becken und die Blicke
abschütteln
das Schwimmen ist mehr als Therapie und
Training es ist auch gut fürs Gemüt
und im Schwimmen einfach die
freiheitliche
fliegen und war sehr gut
[Musik]
was löst Philips Anblick bei anderen aus
im ersten Moment Irritation und dann
viele Fragen
peinlich oder
Frage oder oder sei dir das bin ich und
gestorben zu und du hast ganz normal mit
mir reden normaler Mensch das nur meine
Hut
für niedersteckend
viel zu irritiert sind und das trifft
also ich habe nichts gesehen
eigentlich
sehr
seltener Abstand halten und sich nicht
überfordert sind
sehr fasziniert aber mit der Ort mit der
positiven Ort und er hat
tagsüberblick passiert ist aber
wie die Stärke Behinderte und seine
Konfrontation
[Musik]
Freunde
gemeinsam aufgewachsen in 2000
Seelendorf Hochfelden gemeinsam im Turm
oder im Schießverein sie treffen sich
jeden Donnerstag
für mich ist es einfach was der erlaubt
dieses das und privat noch wieso und und
da kommt mir viele viele Benziner
mit dem angefangen hat also Extremsport
gemacht es ist
hat sich extrem verändert und zum
Positiven
der Sport hat mich Lieferanten
nach dem Unfall waren seine Freunde für
Philipp da ohne Familie und Freunde
hätte er wohl nicht überlebt sagen die
Ärzte sie haben alles manche
Möglichkeiten
auf der Intensivstation
Freunde einer nach dem anderen heiratet
gründet eine Familie
auch für Philipp ist dieses Kapitel
nicht abgeschlossen heute rumfahrt
passiert sie ist in der Beziehung
das hatten wir nicht mehr gestanden
und ich habe mir ganz klar extrem
Gedanken gemacht wirst du wieder jemals
im Partner finden und haben mir auch
einen Druck du das aufgesetzt aber das
ist mittlerweile ist es so wie zurück
und sekundär für mich und und
überhaupt nicht wo jetzt wichtig ist
also wenn es rund ist es umso schöner
aber ich glaube denn ich sau der
richtige Zeitpunkt momentan bin ich
solche
mich selber aus
Besuch im Spital
philipp hat den Kontakt zu pflegenden
und Ärzten stets aufrechterhalten
die Zeit auf der Intensivstation
verbrannt verletzte hat
zusammengeschweißt
die Station wo ihr ein ganzes Jahr
verbracht hat ist heute verweist sie
wurde in einen moderneren Gebäudeteil
verlegt ein leeres Zimmer voller
Erinnerungen
[Musik]
und ich glaube auch tauge ist das
einzige was man von mir gesehen hat
schon alles
die ganze Verband und ich bin auch Plage
und ich mache mir erinnere
dass ich Frage gestellt habe auf dem
Sport übergeben Sport machen und ich
würde gerne Downhill Velofahrer wieder
und dann
natürlich
überhaupt nicht in der Situation
empfunden dass ich jetzt das so total
lieb Schrank bin ja dem Baum habe ich
einfach vor allem
die Jahreszeit
wie eigentlich die Jahreszeiten
[Musik]
zwei Monate künstliches Koma dann ein
halbes Jahr in dem Philipp sich nicht
bewegen konnte wie es unter den
Verbänden aussah wusste er nicht die
Verbände wurden unter Vollnarkose
gewechselt
obwohl immer am Kopf der verbunden ist
dass meine lange Haare weg sind
ja und dann habe ich manchmal noch mehr
Speaker gefragt mit der pflegen
und das ist eigentlich so
interessant Sie also so wir sind draußen
und dann hat sich das wie erledigen für
mich
guten Morgen
sehr gut eigentlich war es mir immer gut
aber
es tut mir immer sehr gut
intensiv Flagge
und und Physiotherapeuten und und
Behandlungs das ist schwer zu einer
Familie wurde wo es mir auch offen sehr
sehr schöne Art mich
glaube mit dem Team zusammen als wir die
Bilder von seinem fünften Jahrestag vom
Unfall hatten also seinen ersten
Triathlon gemacht hat
letztes Jahr ich glaube da sind einigen
die Tränen in den Augen gestanden und
Team war wirklich ergriffen von dem was
möglich ist
wie jeder schwerbrand Verletzte musste
Philipp Schmerzen aushalten die die
Persönlichkeit verändern und wie jeder
schwer Brand verletzte spielte er mit
dem Gedanken sein Leben zu beenden um
den Schmerzen zu entkommen
[Musik]
was mir so lieblich
von der Verbandswechsel da sagt man sehr
lange mit Narkose gemacht weil das gar
nicht möglich ist aber dann zurück
hat sich für mich so so arg gefühlt wer
als Würmer innen innen Busch mit mit
Rosen geschubst werden wo ganz viel
Stachel hat
und so hat sich das auch gefühlt das ist
Auge sind aufgegangen Realität hat sich
wieder
überein kurz Rücken
das ist wirklich so als in der Drucker
das Gebüsch gesehen
und um ganze Körper hat gestochen und
Wetter es gab Situationen wo er wirklich
tief getaucht ist wo es ihm gar nicht
gut ging und wo wir auch das Gefühl
hatten dass er den Weg mit uns gerade so
nicht weitergehen kann
wo wir danach mit seiner Familie
geschaut haben wo wir als
Behandlungsteam über die Bücher sind ob
das für ihn die richtige Weg ist wo wir
auch Grenzen für uns definiert haben wie
weit wir noch gehen können wenn er
wirklich nicht mehr mag
das hat dann das geht wieder in den
ethischen Bereich rein
Zurechnungsfähigkeit von Patienten was
wie sollen wir das Verwerten was der
Patient uns gegenüber äußert
er hat in anderen Situationen erzählt
dass er einerseits nicht mehr hat mögen
aber andererseits auch sich selbst das
Wesens verändert wahrgenommen hat
aufgrund der ausgeprägten Schmerzen und
dann auch Phasen hatte wofür seine
Umwelt ja nicht der Philipp Bossard ist
der vorher war oder der heute ist
also mich schüttelt das aber
Michael immer stramm gehört und hat er
sich in Verbindung mit dem Zug gebracht
und kann mir einfach so vorstellen wenn
ich jetzt die Chance hätten würde ich
das mache klar ganz zum Glück nicht aber
man macht sich so so Gedanken und das
ist schon die
die duscht oder die dunkelsten
Intensivstation sind
motivationsposter schien zu wirken die
Faser mit Selbstmordgedanken ist bei
Philipp sehr kurz verglichen mit anderen
Patienten auch körperlich geht es
langsam aufwärts wieder ohne Hilfe
trinken das erste Mal aufstehen kleine
Fortschritte mit großem Einsatz verdient
das sind die ersten Schritte x
mit
Begleitung und Stütze und
da hat das ganze intensiv Team klatsched
und einem
das ist für mich
also das ist ein großer meilersteig
sieht die ersten zwei Schritte
nach einem Jahr darf Philipp die
Intensivstation verlassen Richtung
Rehaklinik
Philipp findet Anschluss in der Gruppe
von Francesca brennni
sportphysiotherapeutin mit einem
Händchen für Menschen mit Handicap
früher tätig in der Rehaklinik bellicon
heute selbstständig
ich habe den null Erfahrung mit
verbrennungspatienten oder mindestens in
dem Stadion ich hatte
illusan in eine Praktikum ein in der
verbrennungszentrum
verbrennungspatienten gesehen aber in
der Frühphase wo Intensivstation das was
sie hat auch mit der Philip einfach
besucht und das war für mich so wow also
es ist das schwierige Situation was er
gerade erlebt und dann ist auf mich
zugekommen und er hat mir das einfacher
gemacht muss ich ehrlich sein also
philipp ist einfach ein Sonnenschein er
kommt und er macht dir das Leben
einfacher und mit ihm habe ich
dann
geredet viel geredet am Anfang was er
will und dass er nicht will und ich habe
bemerkte ist ein bisschen ziellos
unterwegs gewesen weil man hat ihm
eigentlich als Pflegefall gestempelt und
ja du lebst sei froh dass du lebst das
war einfach so ein bisschen der philipp
am Anfang und ich habe ihm einfach die
Ziele einfach wie reingeworfen und
probiert ich kann sie einfach immer
Worten
gehört wie sie auch die andere Patienten
die tatsächlich
gefördert hat und das hat mir auch sehr
imponiert und ich habe gewiss ich
brauche das alle super
Grill heißt auch raus aus der Turnhalle
der Rehaklinik rein in die
Öffentlichkeit sich unter Menschen
trauen
[Musik]
das erste Mal dass wir sind
Snowboarden gegangen in Davos
er hat nicht geschlafen das weiß ich
weil er hat mir erzählt ich habe nicht
keine schlafe und bei ihm ist war immer
viel etwas Neues wo
kann ich nicht und dann ich habe Angst
aber ihm weiter gewachsen und und dann
er hat das gemacht oder auch Matthias
Matthias sarratima auch viel mitgenommen
und viele Sachen gemacht und und da
glaube ich es macht viel aus mit
Francesca und seinem Freund Matthias
fühlt sich Philipp sicher er erlebt
viele erste Male das erste Mal
Langlaufen das erste Mal auf dem
Snowboard
die erste passward
der erste Halbmarathon
Straße
und jetzt macht er den Halbmarathon 2
Stunden oder
Francesca premier hat Philips Leben
einen Sinn und eine Struktur gegeben mit
dem Sport Job erledigt noch lange nicht
ich bin sportvise ich habe eigentlich
mein Ziel erreicht mit ihm
logischerweise als Freundin muss ich
sagen
ich hoffe dass er er wird auch so etwas
beruflich finden dass er sie auch Spaß
macht und ihm weitere Ziele darum habe
ich auch vorher gesagt für mich ist es
noch nicht fertig also er ist noch nicht
auf der Punkt dass er fertig ist ich
glaube das er braucht noch andere Ziele
aber er ist jung und er kann sicher noch
sich weiterentwickeln und viel lieber
ist jemand der guckt nach vorne und das
glaube ich erata alle Chance das zu
machen dass ich auch die
Selbstständigkeit weiterführen und
das sind das ist der Wegweiser XIV von
ihrer Situation
zum loslag
aber auch jetzt immer noch also sie wird
und ist schon Begleiter lebenslang für
mich
ja
[Musik]
das Engadin je länger je mehr Philips
zweite Heimat er ist vor der Sommerhitze
in Bülach geflohen nur in der Kühle der
Berge kann er trainieren weil er nicht
schwitzen kann Philips vernarbte Haut
hat keine Schweißdrüsen mehr
[Musik]
für mich ist Training beweglich und
Bewegung ich glaube es Qualität und ich
komme sehr gerne meine ganze jetzt im
körperlichen im Training ich glaube ich
haben vorher messen im Spital auf der
intensive schmerzliche Grenzen hoch und
das hat sich schon immer manifestiert in
mir und und das lohnt sich jetzt halt
auch wie im Training aus das mag ich
auch sehr gern und wie gesagt beweglich
ist Freiheit für mich und im Spital bin
ich halt immer gefesselt Perspektive
es ist ein Neustart hier ist Philipp
kein Unfallopfer er ist einfach nur
Sportler er führt das Leben eines
profi-triathleten
ja das ganze Wohlbefinden auch in der
neuen Hut
in der ganzen anderen
es ist schwer so
das ist sicher tritt im Hintergrund das
ist der Philipp als Mensch und nicht so
spezielle und dass du mir auch schon
sehr gut
einfach nur Athlet außerdem Teil einer
Trainingsgruppe
Gleichgesinnte die Geborgenheit stiften
Philips Trainerin Semira bontoniali
erlebt ihren Schützling als beflügelt
ich muss ein eher mal bremsen also sie
möchte
mache oder nicht sondern es ist wirklich
so dass dass der Philipp sehr sehr
motiviert ist und sehr diszipliniert
er lernt auch sehr schnell aber
hinterfragt immer sehr lang bis er den
Mal findet das passt er schaut sich an
mich so ein bisschen weg wenn es Hilfe
fragen tut
Semira ist die rechte Hand von Brad
Satin der auch zahlreiche weltklasse
Athleten betreut der Australier
interessiert sich keinen Deutsch für die
Vergangenheit seiner Sportler nur für
ihre Ziele
wenn Menschen ein Handicap haben oder
ein Problem wie Philipp versuche ich das
zu ignorieren damit Sie sehen ich
behandle sie gleich wie alle anderen
wenn ich mich mit ihrer Geschichte
befasse werde ich emotional das wissen
wenige aber ich bin ein emotionaler Typ
Philipp wird genau gleich und manchmal
genauso streng angepackt wie der Rest
ich denke er genießt das weil viele
Leute ihm nicht die Wahrheit sagen wir
sind ehrlich miteinander wenn er keinen
guten Job macht stauchen wir ihn
zusammen wie alle anderen auch
[Musik]
so unglaubliche Natur wo da wo man um
sich hat das ist für mich sicher ein
sehr großer Energielieferant auch für
für Training und vor allem Motivation so
zum kontraststall zu dem was sie haben
im Spital ist das
Freiheit und das das Gott
[Musik]
zurück in Lokal
Philips Nervosität ist verflogen seine
Freunde machen aus dem Rennen einen
Triumph
[Musik]
und dank Kühlweste und kühlstirnband
trotz Philipp der Hitze
nach zwei Stunden und 51 Minuten darf er
sich Finisher nennen doch die Zeit
spielt keine Rolle
[Applaus]
großes Ziel und sport tut mir so gut
auf dem Wagen unterstützen
diese überhaupt nicht selbstverständlich
für mich
ja wunderschön
Menschen haben Ziele philipp hat seine
erreicht er hat dafür gekämpft mit aller
Kraft aber er weiß alleine hätte er es
nicht geschafft
[Musik]